neal baer d'animaux
attention un v6
les données pour court à tout le monde
et autant céder par les nibards ça vous
plairait vous que les filles et tout le
temps les yeux rivés sur votre nexus
reçu le pénis des mickeys comparable à
celui d'un bébé à l'air libre
je grandis pages comprend pas qu est-ce
qui va pas chez moi est ce qu on est
juste des monstres ma mère dit que la
vraie beauté se cachent à l'intérieur
comme votre côlon ont dû casser paquet
de merde qui pense que les gars on
s'intéresse pas à notre intelligence
on vit déjà dans une société tu fais une
fixette sur le corps féminin et
psychologiquement sarah page
venez je peux pas être excité en même
temps un garçon corey leçon
oh merde
les parents de cette petite sont en
train de débarrasser il faut qu'elle se
débrouille je suis déjà dans la chambre
toi ma dent tâche à bien
c'était magnifique
ce que je veux c'est être normal
[Musique]
mon dieu tu veux dire que nick a tripoté
qu'est ce que tu viens de dire que tu
étais c'est pas du café c'est de la
faute de quelques tu veux que je pète la
forme ou quoi
à
ce flip en bout c'est dans la cuvette je
supporterai pas d'entendre quelqu'un
dire que le voisin de poils pubiens
à
[Musique]